hi how are you good tell us a conference
so far cool right
I'm Maximiliano you can see its have a
long name right um you have learned
yesterday that we can do something with
the name like for example with
accessibility remember that that so you
can call me m9o if you want okay that
will be fine or chef max so let me try
to explain what I'm going to tell you
about right now so we are going to talk
about web performance and why this is so
important so let me first go really
quickly about myself so I'm a mobile web
developer so I have been doing web
development for a while since that
browser I remember that one I've been
traveling a lot this is my 69 country so
a lot of countries okay so mostly for
conferences trainings at companies you
can find content of my own several
publishers I have also a couple of books
okay and the last two books are about
this topic
okay so web performance but I have two
goals it's not to talk about myself my
two goals are make you feel bad okay so
that's the first goal so keep that in
mind and also show you new new tricks
okay things that you can do right now
for for web performance so let's start I
know you know so because you are here
your front-end developers or designers
and so I know that you know that your
users are not happy okay and you are
basically losing money okay so why is
that because your web is slow your
website your web app is slow so and it's
mostly a front-end responsibility that I
know that you know that you're not going
to blame the server okay or DevOps or
whatever it you might have issues there
but it's not really the common scenario
it's typically a front-end problem so we
need to take responsibility for the web
performance so and also I know that you
know that page load is not really
important so no one is currently
measuring page load so we are using some
metrics that are user centric so such as
first meaningful paint or first
interactive or even speeding
I know explain these right now because
I'm pretty sure that you know that right
anyway also I'm pretty sure you know
that there are some goals in the
industry right now you might have
different goals but at least please set
up your goals your performance goals in
terms of the seconds that you want these
metrics on your website so just one two
three seconds four first meaningful
paint or two two four four first
interactive or spinning index between
two and three or 2,000 or 3,000 if
you're using milliseconds so and I also
know that you're already doing a lot of
stuff such as optimizing the network
transfer justice checking if ship is
enabled for all your text-based requests
or responses including JSON for example
you're also working with TLS and HTTP -
pretty sure you're doing that so you're
using CSS as appetizer so as most
appetizers it should be a small okay and
before the main meal that's the whole
idea and you're using javascript as
dessert okay so also small okay and at
the end so I'm sure you're doing this
and you're also optimizing images
this is plain basic web performance
optimization
I'm also know that you are defining an
HTTP cache policy so that's really
important so stop googling how to
disable the HTTP cache okay so you need
to make the HTTP cache your friend and
also I know that you are using service
workers right how many of you are using
service workers right now okay I should
see more hands maybe next year so I know
that you're already in doing this okay
this is not new so all the stuff that
I've been covering so far it's basic web
performance optimization tricks so you
must be doing this so what's the problem
so why am I here so right now if you
look at the stats this is from HTTP
archive this is from April so in first
content we'll paint on the desktop the
median is 2.4 seconds which so
that one only more what is 5.8 and when
I'm when we're talking about time to
interact tips so basically at one point
the website or the web app it's actually
useful okay
the median is eight done dot nine
seconds and I'm sure some of you may be
thinking well that's that's not bad okay
it's around nine seconds okay it's not a
big problem okay but do you know how
long is 8.9 seconds on the web let's see
I don't know why you're laughing is that
so when you're trying to access some
content right now on a mobile device
there is more than 50% of your users
that's the median time to actually use
the content the media okay so we have a
problem okay so we need to do better so
that we are all here listening to web
performance so in fact if we take all
the landings so you will see it's 22
seconds okay that's a report from Google
that's a lot 22 seconds you know what
you need to second see so don't worry
I'm not going to do the same thing again
so but when you look at other stats if a
page takes more than three seconds to
load more than half of the user will
leave it so we are in a problem okay and
one of the biggest problems here is that
we are front-end developers or designers
we have been always under estimating the
mobile space okay so for example right
now we can say iOS and Android
pretty much the more space yeah 97
percent which is fine but is that Safari
and Chrome is that how it looks like so
when you look at the stats I mean more
than 70 percent is Safari and chrome but
we also have a lot of other browsers
with actual market share but there are
even more important than IE it is I'm
still seeing people's caring about ie
Levin for example but not about these
browsers with more than the IE market
share for example the Samson
sir is that one okay you see web Opera
Mini and that one that looks like Chrome
but that's Chrome on iOS and Chrome on
iOS is not actually Chrome okay
so probably ever tried your websites
there are you measuring performance
there I'm having them one more important
browser here that one and you're
thinking hey well that's the old icon
let's use a new one so that's not the
browser well actually it is it's called
the Facebook mobile browser when you
click on a Facebook post or AB you your
website's being rendered inside Facebook
so have you ever try your website there
how it looks like what api's do you have
available there because that's not the
same browser the default browser that is
running on your phone also we are using
cellular networks and I'm sure you're
thinking well we have 4G now so 5g is
coming we don't need to worry about
performance well let me give you some
information here from 3.6 billion mobile
Internet users that we have a couple of
months ago December so only 60% are
smart phones ok and 43 percent are in 4G
and how many of you are in 4G both of
you right
which sounds good but I'm pretty sure
that you have seen this so sometimes a
lot of a lot of places you're not in 4G
you have a 4G phone a 4G data plan
you're in a city with 4G coverage but
you are being downgraded to 3g but when
we are talking about 2g 3G 4G 5g we are
thinking about bath with okay how big is
the pipe okay to send data but when we
are browsing the web web sites and web
apps that's not really so important so
it's more important to think about the
latency and here you can see the legacy
is pretty big on Gigi and it's going
smaller 4G is really small but when you
compare 4G so those lucky 4G users with
a
fell at home it's really big so that's a
problem that we still have in 4G
remember the latency or round-trip time
it's the time that it takes for TCP
packets for the data to actually get to
the destination and for every resource
that you have in your website page
loading you're adding the round-trip
time so think about that okay even on 4G
we have a problem the latency so we
still have a big performance problem on
the mobile web and I'm not sure if you
have heard about this have you ever
heard about Chrome light beiges only two
or three how many of you are on Android
or Android users okay a lot so this has
arrived in chrome 73 on Android so most
of you okay so if you enable data saver
so it's a it's a settings that you can
enable and now if you install chrome
from the Play Store for the first time
you will see a dialog like that one say
hey do you wanna enable data saver so if
you enable that and then a light page
will be rendered if you are in a juicy
network you can say well that's not
common okay that's not common but there
is an or okay operator there and the or
operator says if first contents will
paint estimation is greater than five
seconds
chrome will activate light beiges so it
means even if you're in 4G you're in
Wi-Fi at home and you're visiting a
website and chrome estimates that that
website will take more than five seconds
to achieve first contents will paint it
will activate light pages what is light
page a light page is something that says
light okay but it's cloud based render
so it's like some kind of Opera Mini if
you remember Opera Mini so it has some
smart optimizations wherever that means
and then it will for example not loading
all the images so you probably don't
want that for your website so think
about this a lot of Android users can
now be seen your website if it's a slow
without image is by default
and then the user has the option to load
the image is manually okay so you don't
want this you want to basically reduce
the probability of Chrome light pages so
you can try it so you can go to chrome
flags in your Chrome for Android browser
and use search for override effective
connection type you select yugi and then
you're not going to be browsing into g
it's not throughout in the network it's
just changing the connection type and so
it will activate light pages so you can
actually try it on your android also we
know that pwace are a thing today we
have pwace on desktop now so you can
install pwace on iOS on desktop on
Android but I'm not sure if you know
that right now you can have pwace in the
Play Store so for example I know that
you know have been talking about this
before so for example right now if you
go to trending in the Play Store
there is one app 1-800 flowers that is
actually a PWA so it's in the Play Store
but it's a pwace not there and it's not
an Android native app so and what is
important is using a technology known as
trusted web activity TWA and to use that
technology your content must achieve a
performance score of 80 in lighthouse
which means you must be fast okay so
there are many reasons then why we need
to achieve a really great performance so
we need your hack web performance we
need to do more so I'm pretty sure you
are doing everything that I've been
covering so far but we need more so
let's hack it I'm going to start talking
about the first low so the first
impression okay is the most important
one so when the user is accessing your
website for the first time so I'm going
to start talking about the round-trip
room and the latency that we have on
cellular networks we need to try I mean
we can't change the latency but now that
we know the latency is there we can try
to do a lot of work to make our content
more it's a compatible we'll put that
latency so
without getting too deep into TCP
Bradley you have heard this so when
you're sending a file over the Internet
that file is split in several smaller
packets okay so you can you can send
different packets or the browser is
going to receive different packets so
each TCP packet will have that latency
so we need to avoid more than one
round-trip to to ask for more packets so
the problem is how big are those packets
so that's it's a difficult question to
answer so how big a TCP packet is
because it's something that changes with
time on the client server relationship
but there is something that we know then
it's the first TCP packet so the first
TCP packet using something known as tcp
slow-start algorithm that roughly means
that on linux based servers that are
most of the service right now it's by
before 14.6 kib and here I will open a
parenthesis and I have a warning for you
this is probably the only thing that you
remember from this conference okay so
remember that kiv what is that have you
ever heard about that in fact how many
bytes do we have in a kilobyte it seems
like a simple question right how many
bytes in a kilobyte both of you will say
1024 right well I'm sorry to tell you
that's wrong okay it's a thousand and if
you don't believe me okay you can ask
Siri you can ask Google you can ask
Wikipedia it's 1,000 I'm sorry to tell
you this so it has been for 20 years by
the way so it's not new so we have
something known as a kilobyte okay the
key be byte is the one that it's binary
so that's the one that is 1024 okay so
one kilobyte and that's the I there it's
ten three four so when you want to be
technical
accurate when you're saying something
you need to use these units so closing
parentheses we need to avoid one more
than one roundtrip
okay and on Linux based system that's
14.6 kilobytes so the thing is except
that means that if you are your first
HTTP response is usually the HTML so if
you are sending an HTML of 15 kilobytes
it won't fit in one TCP packet so you
have a problem if you want to achieve
the greatest performance so you need to
keep it in 14.6 kilobytes but maybe
you're thinking that's not too much well
first you're shipping the content so so
that's she saved so that's around 70
kilobytes okay or 70 K of HTML which
might not be so bad so that also we need
to start thinking about this when you're
browsing a website we have something
known as the above the full content
that's what you see before scrolling
okay and all the user centric metrics
are focused on that part only so then we
have below the full content so I'm sorry
for Kyle will love Kyle okay but for the
user centric metrics Kyle is not
important there okay so we need to focus
on the above the phone sorry guy but so
we need to focus there so that means
that if we can deliver only the ATF
count and the above the full content in
14.6 kilobytes we can achieve really
great performance because it will fit in
one TCP packet okay so that's the first
tip and we can embed all the CSS and
JavaScript if you really need javascript
okay for that so you can embed that so
I'm talking about the style tag not the
link not an external we don't want
another HTTP request with a roundtrip
so and even if you have a space you can
embed your logo in SVG or a low
resolution version of your logo very
high compressed JPEG or something like
that okay in base64 directly in that
HTML so another important thing is to
avoid the HTTP
- HTTP ready rekt so now we are moving
everything to http
but when users are typing a URL the
browser is going to HTTP by default okay
and then when we are making a redirect
and that's basically a stop sign for
performance so because the browser needs
to stop there and say oh no it's not
here you actually need to go there and
the process starts again and we are
losing a lot of time so I'm asking you
to start using HSTs this is a spec that
lets you add a header in cure your first
HTTP response saying hey browser you
know what in this domain we only speak
secure connections so from now on you
always need to go to HTTPS and when you
do that then you can preload your
website directly in that URL and your
browser's will add you in a whitelist so
next time another user there is a new
user for you is trying to get you your
content then that user will go directly
to HTTPS and you can save around half a
second and half a second is a lot
because we don't have too much budget we
have a tiny tight budget for performance
so that's for an initial load now let's
talk about how to hack data transfer but
it's also important because we have more
things to send not just the HTML so let
me mention quickly quick over HTTP so
this is an experimenter transport
protocol over UDP not CCP again I'm not
going to get too deep here but it
reduces the latency and connection
messages that are needed to actually
receive a content from the server and
it's usually an HTTP 2 interface TLS so
it looks the same as we are doing right
now it's something you need to enable or
add as an add-on in your server and this
is how the official diagram this this
protocol comes from Google is an open
protocol it's available on chromium
based browsers so the important part
here is that when you are using quick
okay you need to look at that part of
the diagram so you have
less connection messages and if the
connection is repeated then it's zero
latency so there is no need for sending
packets all over the network so quick
right now it's improving performance on
Google on this reducing above buffering
on YouTube Facebook for the native app
they are using a similar protocol based
on quick and it's also improving
performance and according to a Google
research 3/4 of all the requests on the
web can be actually optimized thanks to
quick and by the way this is officially
HTTP over quick that's the name if you
want to google that and the most
important part here is that this is the
draft of HTTP 3 so this is becoming HTTP
3 so you can start using it right now
and then at one point you will upgrade
this to the final version of the
protocol but you can start saving bytes
today okay for your users using it as
quick over HTTP then we have something
known as softly-softly it's a new
compression algorithm over ship that can
save you data so everything that you're
shipping you can actually use softly for
that if you see most more CPU but CPU
it's not like a big issue right now so
you can start using it and this is
compatible with ie6 if you want to
provide that content but even more
important we have broadly it's it's
incredible how many servers are not
broadly compatible yet today because now
every browser is broadly compatible so
birth is a different compression system
instead of ship and you can set up to 3
5% so remember that 14.6 kilobytes well
now we can feed more HTML in one TCP
packet if we use broadly it's around 80
ok ok so you just checked in : header so
if the browser is compatible you're
going to send a broadly package if not
she sipped so check if your server or
your CDN is supporting broadly and if
not try to ask how to add it so LinkedIn
has say
4% in low time Facebook has a lot of
savings base if it CSS or JavaScript
we're talking about text-based content
and now resource loading because hTML is
not alone and it's not just about bytes
we are loading also a lot of resources
so we have new cache control so for
example if you're using react view
angular sealife it's common today to use
hash in the file name okay so when we
are sending a Dutch bundled ojs file or
bundle dot CSS file to the client we
know for sure for sure that that URL
will never change so there is no need
for a conditional request there is no
need for the browser to ask to the
server hey I have a version of that file
you have a new one there is no need for
that because if we change the content if
we build our app again and that file has
changed the whole URL will change
because it's a different hash so now we
can specify that with a new modern cache
control okay its cache control immutable
okay so if you say so then the browser
will not send a conditional request
which means you will save a lot of time
when loading those files also for those
of you working with service workers
there is a new pattern available today
that is pretty common that means that
you serve a file from the cache so it
might be outdated because it's served
from the cache and also you update the
content okay in the background for later
ok now you can specify that pattern to
the browser okay
it's known as a stale wire revaluate and
it's currently available in Firefox and
Chrome and also because cache control
lets you use multiple values you can
have a fallback anyway so you can ask
the browser to start using this pattern
for the browser cache so that's pretty
cool something that is even more
important is warming up engines and for
now we have been talking about things
that have to do with the server
configuration HTTP headers but if it's
something that you can
change in your HTML so warming up
engines we need to help the browser to
start processes as soon as possible
so because the DNS query can take up to
200 milliseconds on a 3G network and the
same for the TCP and TLS connection and
that's a lot of time so we can announce
DNS queries as soon as possible ok with
a linked DNS prefetch so we can say hey
browse or you know what later you will
need to download a CSS or a font file
from that other domain so please start
the DNS query right now so also you can
announce TLS connections like please
start the TLS connection there directly
I'm talking about talking to the server
opening the connection to the server you
can also use these not just in the HTML
but also you can add it a financial TP
header so even before the browser is
actually parsing your HTML the browser
will know that it will need a connection
to another server ok it can be Google
phones for example a CDN where you are
downloading your important resources
pre-loading maybe you have how many of
you have here about preload ok she has
to feel like 10% so it helps the browser
prioritize resources for rendering so in
this case you're not going to say start
the TCP connection or a DNS query you're
going to say hey I want that file I know
that you don't know that you will need
that file but I know that so please go
and download that file so you can say
that you a CSS file but also you can say
that for example to the wolf file for
web fonts so and you can increase a lot
of per for your performance metrics
applying these if you're using web fonts
right so and there are a couple of new
things here now when you're using
preload
also in the IMG tag you can specify the
importance so how important is that so
you can change the priorities the
default priorities in the browser using
that importance attribute so you can
start using this right now another usual
question that I get is to bundle or not
to bundle
okay so I'm writing JavaScript or CSS
and okay I have 105 should I bundle the
files or not so even on HTTP 2 it might
seems like an adding pattern because
there is no need for for doing this we
have better TCP connection usage and
also we have HTTP header compression but
it's not it's still a good idea to do
this okay so this is a tweet from Paul
Irish saying that you know what
basically we still need to bundle it's
the best way to achieve the best
performance with JavaScript and CSS but
I'm not saying bundle everything ok
first we need to do Co splitting and
just send what is important for the
initial render and then you can load the
rest yesterday there were some talks
talking about for example dynamic
hydration if you're using react or other
tools so you still need to do that but
for all the files that are needed for
the initial rendering bundle that file
ok that's important because it will save
a lot regarding web fonts you coming up
here using web some web fonts in your
web sites okay so it's not a lot which
is good right so web fonts are really
annoying because we have something known
as flash of unstyled text so that we see
an image we see the logo and no text
because there is no font so you need to
start using font display optional swap
this is currently available on mostly
every browser which is good news right
because with these you can specify what
do you want to do is for example the
user is near juicy connection or is in
roaming or has data saver enable you
know what the phone is taking too much
time to load well swap it to another
phone or this is optional don't try it
don't even try ok this is from last week
on Google now with Google phones you can
add an attribute when you are requesting
the CSL from Google phone is specifying
your font display policy so please
do this and then we have images so we
know how that images are really
important okay
a picture is worth a thousand words but
the problem is you need to load right
because we have been up doesn't work
okay so now we have a lot of things that
we can do for example we can preload
responsive images so if you have been
using the picture element okay for for
Responsive images now you can do on the
preload the sources and sizes so you can
actually move all that responsive logic
to there preload came so this is pretty
cool now and this is also from a new
from Google i/o you can do LaCie image
loading okay with loading lazy just an
attribute so that is pretty simple and
basically means that by default when you
say lazy those images the image is below
the fold will be low that only when they
are in the viewport okay so we are
saving a lot of bandwidth okay thanks to
dit and this is also available on
iframes which is pretty cool as well
okay so we can start focusing on the ATF
content and then we can start
downloading the rest of this pretty cool
it's also time to replace a standard
JPEG and PNG file I'm not talking about
new formats there are a lot of new
formats coming even wipey but yeah I
still tricky to get it you get it well
done but now we have new compression
algorithm for PNG like softly and also
for JPEG gastly so these are new
compression algorithm that we will will
push performance further on your current
images without changing compatibility
because this works on ie 5 probably ok
and the last part that I have for you is
how do you hack the user experience so
let me first talk about HTTP hot line
hints so because this is really
interesting
and it's currently underused in the
market the idea is the browser can
expose data to the server you need to
opt in through an HTTP header or a
method I'll saying you know what browser
I won't
next request that you're making to my
server I want to know more information
about the clients okay I can increase
the user experience so you can ask for
round-trip time latency so you can
actually know your server how's the
current latency and make decisions
server-side about the experience that
you want to provide you that user
downlink that's are basically bands with
an estimation of the bandwidth as this
is connection type 2g 3G 4G okay save
data so this is a boolean flag that will
tell you you know what the user has data
saver enable DPR device pixel radius of
density pixel density and view / width
and also you can ask for device memory
which is kind of cool because now you
can know if it's a feature phone okay
off or if it's really a smart phone or
an extra computer and change for example
the image file that you're sending so
and by the way device memory the API
from the w3c is sending you that actual
device memory in M IV and that's not men
in black okay now you have learned that
maybe bite okay so so now you know that
okay remember that so and that leads to
something that is known as reactive web
performance so because typical web
performance optimization works
statically so we analyzed our website we
measure and we apply some techniques and
that's all
reactive web performance that you can
actually know about the context with
some several api's such as the network
information api performance of servers
so this is a a couple of API available
where you can receive information about
what's going on like for example if you
have an a script tag or if you have a
function that if they key is it's like
using the thread more than 50
milliseconds and you can get information
about that on that particular CPU of
course the save data client hints so you
can actually know if the user has data
saver enabled and the device memory
clients with all these information that
you have from the context you can
actually make decisions client-side or
server-side to deliver a consistent
experience because maybe I'm on as a
Galaxy S 10 okay but I'm in roaming and
I mean gg
so don't send me a Galaxy S 10
experience I want to see something
that's why Chrome is creating light
beiges because it's better to see
something than nothing okay because if
not the user will just abandon your
website or your web app so in terms of
the consistent experience you can choose
to load or not web font based on the
previous information that we have been
gathering to change the serviceworkers
cache policy so make a change based on
that SSR versus clients are rendering so
we can change this based on the current
context maybe the user is in a very
low-end phone with bad connection maybe
with low memory maybe client surrender
is not a good idea and you can reduce
the amount of loads of data to keep a
consistent experience also for example
even if it's a really high density phone
but the latency or the boundary is not
good enough just send a low resolution
image okay and you now you can get
report from the browser there is a
reporting API
there is a header report - with a server
endpoint and basically the browser will
send you reports about problems
including if chrome light pages are
being activated on your site so you can
actually know this on your server right
now so we have been covering a lot right
so we have seen wide web performance is
important I have to hack the first load
data transfer resource loading images
okay and user experience so remember
performance is top priority really top
priority push it always even more okay
it's really really a worthwhile effort
okay feeling bad enough yeah cool well
that's all thank you
you
[Applause]